hbo's new series the last of us has
begun filming in alberta canada we've
now got the first look at pedro pascal
as joel and bella ramsay's ellie as well
as set photos replicating key locations
from the games and new incomings for the
cast of the show a lot has happened
since the initial announcement of the
show back in 2020 so if there are gaps
in your knowledge or you're a last of us
mega fan looking for all the new
information we have about the classic
series then stay tuned
welcome back everyone to streaming the
galaxy my name is rocket riley and today
we're going to be going over everything
we know so far about hbo's upcoming
series the last of us based on the video
game series of the same name but before
we get started if you're new to the
channel please hit the subscribe button
and click the bell icon to be notified
when we upload a new video while we
don't have a release date for the last
of us series just yet we do have a few
details that give us an idea of when it
will be released
we know filming is already underway
because of videos and photos that have
been released from the series filming
location in calgary alberta one of the
show's directors kantamir balagov has
2022 listed as a release time on their
instagram page and one of the show's
leading actors gabriel luna recently
said in an interview i'm not in the
scheduling department but it'd be sooner
than later before we get to watch the
series
we're expecting production to last all
the way to the middle of 2022 which
means we shouldn't expect to see the
series hit hbo until the end of 2022
so far hbo has only given us a short
synopsis for the show the story takes
place 20 years after modern civilization
has been destroyed
joel a hardened survivor is hired to
smuggle ellie a 14 year old girl out of
an oppressive quarantine zone what
starts as a small job soon becomes a
brutal heartbreaking journey as they
both must traverse across the us and
depend on each other for survival
while this sounds like the main
storyline from the first video game
there are rumors that the show will also
include some of the events from the
second game
the first season is set to have 10
episodes and there have been talks about
a potential second season
it's not yet known if the first season
will cover all of the events of the
first last of us video game but with the
enhancements the directors are making to
the show i think it's likely that the
first season will only cover a portion
of the events of the first game going
more in depth into joel and tommy's past
much of the cast has already been
announced for this series featuring
pedro pascal as the show's protagonist
joel known for his work on game of
thrones and the mandalorian pedro pascal
has already been given the seal of
approval by joel's original voice actor
troy baker saying this is the way full
support full stop can't wait for you to
show me a side of joel i never knew
pedro
the show will also feature bella ramsay
known for her role as lady liana mormont
in game of thrones ramsay will take on
the starring role of ellie a character
known for her fierceness and intensity
just as lady mormont was in game of
thrones
although pascal and ramsay's characters
never interacted in the game of thrones
series i have no doubt that these two
performers will go above and beyond our
expectations for the show
several other characters have been
announced for the series as well
gabriel luna will play tommy and joel's
younger brother luna is known for his
work in terminator dark fate and true
detective meanwhile merle dandridge will
play the firefly's leader marlene just
as she did in the video game
nico parker will play joel's daughter
sarah as parker is known for her role in
tim burton's 2019 reimagining of dumbo
finally the most recent casting news is
that fringe star anna torv will be
playing tess joel's friend and fellow
smuggler who helped joel and ellie in
the first video game con o'neill will
play bill and murray bartlett is set to
play frank the pair are described as two
post-pandemic survivalists living alone
in their own isolated town
tommy's voice actor from the games
jeffrey pearce will play an original
character by the name of perry and one
mysterious character by the name of mr
adler will be played by brad leland
neil druckmann co-president and creative
director of naughty dog games the studio
that brought us the last of us and the
last of us two video games is rumored to
take on the helm of director for an
episode of the series alongside jasmila
zabonik kantamir balagov and ali abbasi
the video games composer gustavo santo
al-nala will be returning to score the
hbo series as well
the first official image of hbo's the
last of us tv show was released in late
september as part of naughty dog
celebration of the last of us day
several set photos and videos have also
been released by the residents of
calgary alberta showing pedro pascal and
bella ramsay on set along with anna torv
certain photos indicate the story's
location continuing in boston while
others display the continuation of the
savage starlight easter eggs found in
the video game
one photo released by gabriel luna on
social media shows tommy and joel before
the series outbreak potentially filming
the opening scene from the first video
game
every photo that gets released just
gives us further insight as to how
closely the show will be following the
storyline of the original video games
well that's gonna be everything from us
today on hbo's new series the last of us
if you enjoyed the video please hit the
like button and don't forget to
subscribe for more great content what
are your thoughts about the new set
photos and casting decisions made is
pedro pascal the right choice for joel
we'd like to know what you think so drop
your thoughts in the comment section
below
from everyone here at stream in the
galaxy we hope you have a great day and
thanks for watching